et on revient sur ce plan de
déconfinement avec nos deux invités
c'est le débat de ce soir avec nos
mathieu lebrun porte-parole des gérants
discothèque de normandie et thierry
amouroux porte parole du syndicat
infirmier sn pays bonsoir messieurs et
merci ea d'être avec nous ce soir
thierry amouroux
plus de cent mille 600 malades sont
encore hospitalisés en réanimation
aujourd'hui ils étaient 2000 lors du
déconfinement en mai dernier
est ce que vous disiez que le
gouvernement va trop vite bien et
surtout qui le procès de mal
c'est à dire que ce qu'il faudrait par
exemple sur les établissements scolaires
qui sont le principal foyer c'est pas un
jour où je ferme c'est je mets des
purificateurs d'air dans chaque salle de
classe dans chaque réfectoire et ça qui
est nécessaire il faut également faire
des deux me classe pour tous les âges de
toutes les classes
voilà il faut gérer au mieux c'est pas
simplement l'interrupteur j'ouvre je
ferme dans le haut niveau de la
restauration pareil ce qu'il faut c'est
installer des purificateurs d'air qui
vont permettre de résoudre le problème
parce que tester c'est bien si derrière
on isole mais une fois vous avez testé
quelqu'un de positif vous pouvez
reconstituer les choses mais c'est pas
ça qui freine la contagion ce qu'il faut
vraiment se doter c'est plus risqué à
tordères dans tous les lieux clos pour
réduire la transmission qui est avant
tout au niveau des aérosols mathieu
lebrun comment est ce que vous vous
réagissez aux nombreux appels à la
prudence
vos patrons de discothèques qui allait
sans doute vivre un deuxième était de
fermeture des mesures comme celle que
vient de nous présenter
thierry amouroux ce sont des choses que
vous pourriez mettre en place dans vos
établissements
bah écoute et effectivement depuis lé
mois de julie manière on propose une
multitude de choses pour pouvoir ouvrir
les établissements effectivement on est
bien conscient au faux-pas de fou
qui est bien une épidémie que c'est
dangereux ça peut entraîner des morts le
président a dit va falloir s'habituer à
vivre ça et travailler peut-être
autrement mais malheureusement et c'est
étonnant mais je rejoins quand même
énormément c'est pour vos propos c'est à
dire que on nous écoute pas c'est à dire
qu'on n'écoute pas les professionnels de
chaque secteur et villages pour mon cas
on explique depuis plus d'un an à
olivier ferrand que nous avons des
extracteurs d'air qui toutes les 8
minutes renouvelle l'air complet notre
établissement effectivement on peut si
on doit rajouter d'autres choses et le
on va le faire le mas tout sa fin bref
on est on est vraiment comblé mais on
écoute pas donc là ce qui va se passer
réellement c'est la même chose que l'été
dernier et on avait déjà prédit ce qui
allait se passer
les jeunes vont se ré se réunir dans des
appartements clos sans gestes barrières
sans masque et tout ce qu'on peut
imaginer pour se protéger et en plus ils
feront pas vacciner parce qu'on va
commencer à vacciner les plus de 18 ans
à partir de mi juin
donc la catastrophe est déjà écrite ça
va recommencer comme on en est là et
voire même pire
c'est juste une cata on ne travaille pas
que les prochaines on ne les écoute pas
effectivement les bars les restaurants
vont se retrouve à faire notre boulot et
je parle aussi par contre au niveau
sécurité on va voir des incivilités des
problèmes de sécurité
parce que les bars les restos sont pas
équipés de deux agents de sécurité
qu'est ce que vous voulez je vous lis et
depuis le mars 2001 où nous sommes
fermés on est on n'écoute pas les
discothèques
on n'écoute pas les professionnels qui
encadrent et qui gère la nuit on a
l'habitude avant le gobie évidemment
thierry amouroux vous enquérir de la
situation dans les écoles est ce que
vous auriez compris que le gouvernement
annonce hier la réouverture prochaine
des discothèques
encore une fois il faut contrôler l'air
dans les lieux clos
c'est vraiment ça qui est important le
gouvernement il a des
des réflexions qui dépasse l'entendement
prenez l'exemple des des avions qui
viennent du brésil ou d'inde
il a fallu tout un lobby pour leur faire
comprendre que il faut arrêter les
trajets les limités du fait de la
présence des variants dans ces pays-là
leur réflexion c'est dire bon on va
faire une quarantaine de dix jours avec
deux heures de sorties par jour voilà
avec eux on n'atteint jamais le fond où
at on vu qu'une quarantaine on avait
deux heures de sorties par jour
c'est largement suffisant au virus pour
se diffuser
voilà et tout est fait en dépit du bon
sens avec ce gouvernement et c'est pour
ça que et ben la france se retrouve le
troisième pays du trio brésil
anne france dans toutes les études
internationales où on se moque de nous
parce qu on a un gouvernement incapable
de gérer correctement les choses
mathieu lebrun selon l'union des métiers
des industries de l'hôtellerie environ
10% des établissements ont déposé le
bilan depuis un an
quelle est votre situation aujourd'hui
est ce que vous continuez de recevoir
des aides de l'état
alors pour l'instant on a toujours les
aides de l'état pour mon cas c'est
suffisant mais on a quand même
énormément de trous dans la raquette et
de mes collègues qui sont obligés de
réinjecter de l'argent personnel
il ne faut pas oublier qu'en plus nous
en tant que gérant ça fait plus qu'un
pratiquement quinze mois nous avons plus
de rémunération parce que ces aides ne
servent qu'à soutenir nos sociétés mais
nous ne pas de rémunération je parle
aussi des congés payés de nos salariés
on a plus d'un an de fermeture deux
jours et demi par mois vous faites le
calcul et l'état nous a donné d'un geste
large 10 jours de congés payés pris en
charge
de l'état mais les comptes sont pas bons
et en plus nous on est victime depuis le
début d'une inégalité de traitement
complètement folle c'est à dire que de
mars à octobre 2020 on n'a rien touché
le temps que les ex des blocs et
compagnie donc il a fallu vivre sur
notre trésorerie le pg je le mets à part
parce que c'est de la dette de la dette
chez tech de la dette en y puisant à
voir le rembourser et maintenant on est
alors on rouvre pas les anciennes aides
les premiers rails que nous avons eu le
premier fonds de solidarité pour les
discothèques n'étaient pas du tout ce
qu'on a maintenant ce qui est beaucoup
mieux ça faut l'avouer il faut le dire
et donc on demande que il y à un retour
sur ce juin à octobre et qu'on récupère
c'est être con devant devrait avoir qui
était équivalent est étonnamment fin aux
hommes
les restaurants les bars on les ferme et
une boutade miracle on nous intègre dans
le processus des bars des restaurants
etc et mieux payés que ceux ce qu'on
avait avant
donc bref depuis le début on est une
inégalité de traitement complètement
dingue je vais pas revenir en plus on
parlait de la santé mais nous sommes
fermés bars restaurants discothèques et
le non essentiel en général fermée sur
aucune étude scientifique depuis le
début je pense qu'au mois de juin 2010
il aurait été bon avec tous les
milliards qu'on a enfin rejeté par tous
de se payer de vraies études digne de
son pour savoir qui est dangereux et qui
ne l'est pas et si auquel cas nous
mettons les discothèques nous sommes
dans le froid est-ce qu'il ya peu suite
et les rouvrir en adaptant notre métier
à aucun moment on parle tous dans le
vent on nous dit vous êtes dangereux et
tout le monde croit sa nette sur parles
tu très étonné voilà donc allons en
train d'imaginer chose on parle les
extracteurs d'air et je reviens sur ces
histoires d'extracteurs d'air au mois de
juillet l'année dernière on a parlé nos
extracteur olivier ferrand a balayé d'un
revers de la main non non ça sert à rien
et au mois c'est le temps le ministre
pour les écoles expliqué que vos
professeurs faut ouvrir les fenêtres au
possible pour aérer les salles de classe
de qui se moque t'on et donc je rejoins
et la même chose ce qui est dit c'est
toute manière il n'ya plus de bon sens
dans ce gouvernement
et je suis bien content que les
massacres on supprime les là parce que
il faut tout recommencer
et surtout le raconte le bon sens à nos
politiques actuelles parce que là c'est
une catastrophe
est-ce que la réouverture de vos
établissements des discothèques
est ce qu'elle sera à ce que vous avez
le sentiment aussi qu'elle sera
conditionnée à une plus large
vaccination des français je pose la
question je vous pose la question avoue
thierry amouroux pfff quel regard est ce
que vous avez porté sur les annonces
faites par le gouvernement quant à
l'élargissement aux dés demain
d'ailleurs de cette vaccination ou plus
de français ça commencera demain donc
avec les les français qui souffrent de
maladies chroniques
c'est très important nous ont réclamé
depuis longtemps en particulier pour les
personnes en surpoids parce que c'est
elle qui arrivent beaucoup en
réanimation et on voit bien qu'il ya un
gros problème là encore en france sur la
vaccination
chaque année pour la grippe annuelle
on vaccine en deux mois entre 10 et 13
millions de personnes chaque année là en
quatre mois on est arrivé que injecter
une seule dose à 15 millions de
personnes et de doses 6 million et demi
de personnes
on voit bien le le décalage énorme
alors c'est sûr que il ya eu attention
une tension se relâche sur les doses
dans l'ensemble des pays du monde et en
particulier dans l'union européenne mais
au sein de l'union européenne la france
est plutôt dans les volets
on est le 13e pays sur les 27
après avoir longtemps été en queue de
peloton et on voit bien que on a un
problème propre à la france avec une
technostructure qui fait que parlant
aujourd'hui on a reçu 25 millions de
doses 22 millions ont été utilisés et à
3 millions de doses qui tourne dans le
circuit
on sait pas où et c'est un peu la
difficulté c'est à dire qu'avec des
agences régionales de santé qui rajoute
une couche supplémentaire avec déjà une
technostructure ministérielle assez
lourde balles et les vaccins sont pas
forcément à l'endroit où on a besoin à
un moment on a besoin donc c'est une
difficulté de plus que l'on à nous
professionnels de santé donc c'est
important d'ouvrir on voit bien que là
non plus il ya eu débat autour d'eux
astrazeneca qui fait que ben certain
nombre de français sont réticents par
rapport à ce vaccin donc on a des plages
non utilisés dans les centres de
vaccination sur astrazeneca alors qu'il
ya de la tension sur chaque zone
falise ce sera le mot de la fin merci à
tous les deux messieurs d'avoir
participé à cet échange tirer amouroux
porte parole des syndicats infirmiers
smp et mathieu lebrun porte-parole des
gérants de discothèques en normandie et
merci à tous les deux et à bientôt sur
arte france